To be
honest, I was a fan of Chama-san, but like
everyone else,
I've always been a game that 03 was produced since I was a student.
I was a person who wanted to make a game by playing, so I thought I should
work with him
.  If that's the case, it's because I'm a new employee
, so it's not a lie
here. That child's building 1 floor is a technique for developing CyberConnect2.
I'm doing it,
but it was also in that tree house, but there is a camera, and this screen is here. This is the camera in that house. This camera is in the
picture right now.
here till oc Everything is always
with Naruto, is
n't it? It's
really a part of my life as I live thinking about what I'm going to do.
Basically, policy is a series of difficulties, so I always suffer.  It's
really hard to make it. I'm working hard to extend my working hours to the limit. All
I can say is that he always has animation every day. Everyone in the
staff likes
animation and watches animation almost every day.  Well, if there are
200 staff members, the box generations are different from around 20 years old to those in their 30s and 40s, so
what they are seeing is also different.
The thing is about 4000 or 8000 to increase it
.
Let me buy clothes from Tokyo. Adv specializing in teeth and
Blueway We always want to see
it.  I'm constantly improving the quality of
various anime works. I'm always studying anime works called Japanese animation works
. Well, I
have the ability to reproduce the appearance of anime
.
This is a little rare, but
it's a teacher of the model who is the original author. Well, this is the actual game of that Ultimate Hero 2.
It may be an illustration of a star that was used in the
game. Well, this
area is no longer
visible in the world. It's
a colored paper that was given to a CyberConnect by that chief teacher
.
Thank you very much for the ceremony from the ceiling of the house with a congratulatory message.
Well, when I was a kid, I jumped every week and read the final thing.
Yeah,
it's different from the old days when you can see the faces of the people who are making it.
When I
was shown the gameplay that I was
doing, I thought that I was doing a really good company salt work, but
I firmly hit the things that I made after that.  There is a
sense of responsibility and a strong feeling of the moon
that I have to do it. I am very happy at that moment and I will do my best
Eido Here is a sound staff Sandur
Hey etc. All the game images that CyberConnect2 deals with here
It's a work of a sound
leader
Yes
Well, there is a baking studio only here compared to other rooms,
but the feeling of the ears is a little different, but yes, next
time I've made it so far  That memory, after all, is
the
moment when the story of Naruto is finished to something
that everyone can sympathize with.  There were a lot of things, so when I was last debugging, I was
crying a little more and debugging
, but
I think that kind of thing is interesting in development, and
I made it myself.  I think that you can cry with something,
maybe you can catch it and tell it to everyone.
Well, there are people like that. Nowadays
,
Yokan Edo Ai, please do that job
.  There is a member who has a movie and a bug 10 minutes.
All games including garden games are
developed here.
Until just before completion, 10 of them a. I will repeat it repeatedly.
After all, when I was making games, I was able to put out a collection of experiences at the event.  There
is, but it's like this. Opinions and reactions from fans during the making process and at the class
. This kind of thing is a surprise of daily development, and it's in making games.
I think it's a source of information like that, but it's still quite good, because that kind of jump, the Tokyo Game
Show, the scene, and the bar deal with quite a lot of customers.
What I was told, I see,
isn't it? Well, this is
the common area of the Nardo team, and here's the latest build
This is a place for a to work again.
This is Paddle Well 4 a
Land that is being adjusted
.
Well, this time it's Event Stone 4
Yes, I think it's
definitely the best
work in my class.
I'm not overestimating myself, but I
think that character games such as Naruto are
currently the best in the world as we are making. Above all, I feel
as
if I became Naruto through play.
For example, I made
a ui that can answer it properly according to my tension even with one input
. What is it? The
most difficult thing is schedule management.
After all, I think that the largest number of groups are weird.
The staff of various tees are really close
to each
other
.